Ta-da!
Hi, it's N-ko.
Anime that Netflix employees like!
We Netflix employees are dedicated to delivering content every day.
We feel deep affection for the titles we deliver.
I was curious about which shows my coworkers around the world liked,
especially considering their deep affection for the titles.
So I had my close coworkers help me
by answering a survey.
I asked about their favorite animation and their animation history.
I received some interesting answers.
I wanted to share their responses with you,
so that's why I planned this video.
So, basically, these are the reactions from abroad.
Okay, let's get started!
This is what was on the survey!
What was your first anime? What anime are you currently watching? Recommendations.
Recommendation for a Netflix original series. Most anticipated Netflix original series.
Some of the answers
were written in great detail, showing their passion for that show.
I could tell that they really loved that anime.
One more thing.
Not all the survey questions were answered by everybody,
so please understand that there will be differences in the contents of their answers.
Now, the results for their very first anime are these!
Three of them answered PRETTY GUARDIAN SAILOR MOON.
The others said DRAGON BALL and NEON GENESIS EVANGELION.
It seems many of their first anime are popular ones.
Looking at the titles of these anime,
they were made in the '80s through the 2000s.
So I thought they were exposed to anime
before anime became a huge international sensation as well.
PRETTY GUARDIAN SAILOR MOON is my absolute favorite too,
so if I get a chance, I'd like to discuss it with my coworkers!
By the way, my very first anime is PRETTY GUARDIAN SAILOR MOON too.
When my neighbor was moving back to Japan,
they gave me a PRETTY GUARDIAN SAILOR MOON VHS, and I watched it every day.
Next is anime they are currently watching.
Here are their answers.
Three answered ATTACK ON TITAN.
It might be the timing when this survey was done,
but ATTACK ON TITAN, with its final season playing right now,
is being watched and loved all over the world.
The rest of the final season is something to look forward to.
And the others with multiples votes, such as
JUJUTSU KAISEN, RE:ZERO, and MY HERO ACADEMIA,
are shows that are also popular in Japan.
ONE PIECE and HAIKYU!! are mentioned.
Animation from Jump comics has been and will continue to be loved globally.
The fact is that BLOOD OF ZEUS, a Netflix original series,
which is not affected by seasonal series
such as spring and summer series, made it to the rankings as well.
This showed that the era where anime could only be watched on TV is over,
and several different forms of animation are accepted now.
Next is anime recommended by Netflix employees.
Netflix employees who know many titles
are only allowed to make one recommendation.
With such heart-wrenching restrictions, which anime are they going to recommend?
I'm very curious about their answers too.
Here are their answers.
Keep in mind that I asked this to my coworkers all over the world.
I didn't expect some of the answers to be the same.
COWBOY BEBOP and FULLMETAL ALCHEMIST are great anime,
but I'm surprised to see how they were so influential all over the world.
Their reasons for recommendation vary.
Some recommended a show for a newbie anime watcher,
and others recommended something because it's their favorite.
Some made the recommendation for the charm of the anime.
All their answers are full of love for their recommendations.
However, if GRAVE OF THE FIREFLIES was recommended to me
and I watched it,
it might have been a tough experience.
Its content is heavy, and depending on your state of mind,
you might end up getting depressed.
It's not limited to anime,
but making a recommendation is quite challenging.
Next is recommended Netflix original series.
I'm curious about what my coworkers like.
Here are their answers.
Three of them answered CASTLEVANIA.
This was created based on Konami's game, Castlevania.
The term "dark fantasy" is the perfect description for this show.
The game's unique world outlook
is represented well in the animation.
I think they've done an amazing job.
Season four started recently,
so it's a great opportunity to binge-watch the whole series.
Also on the list are the very popular GREAT PRETENDER
and BEASTARS.
Another show mentioned is THE WAY OF THE HOUSEHUSBAND.
For this show, we had an online live event
with Kenji Tsuda, the main voice actor.
I am glad to see that most of the popular shows were covered.
I related the most to the reason for recommending DEVILMAN CRYBABY,
and I think I'll say the same thing when I recommend the show to my friends.
Please watch it if your interest is piqued.
Last question on the survey is
the most anticipated Netflix original series in animation.
Several different shows are scheduled for this year,
but which show are they anticipating the most?
I'm very interested in their answers too.
Let's take a look!
Three of them said THE WAY OF THE HOUSEHUSBAND.
I wonder if the combination of a yakuza and househusband
is a globally intriguing and distinctive theme?
It's a good-paced comedy, and the unique character
enhanced by the skills of the voice actor
matches this show perfectly.
It seems easy to follow, which
makes you want to continue watching the show.
This may be the reason why it is so anticipated.
The answer I was interested in was TRESE.
It's set in Manila, the capital of the Philippines,
and a female detective, Trese, protects the city from the evil powers.
It's a horror fantasy show.
I think it's a special show,
where Filipino culture is embodied in the story.
One day, shows won't be categorized as "first time in Japan" or "first time abroad"
in the anime industry.
I think this show represents that.
There are other shows such as YASUKE and SPRIGGAN that are worth watching,
so I'll continue to spread the news among my coworkers too.
What did you think of the recommendations made by Netflix employees?
Now that we can watch anime anywhere in the world,
I think it's wonderful that we can be absorbed in what we love
at the same time, with the same passion.
Anime joins the world!
Is it too dramatic to say that?
If any of the shows we shared today
intrigued you in any way, please go ahead and check them out!
I plan to watch CASTLEVANIA before going to bed tonight.
See you again!